ultimatum abgelaufen die
bundestagsabgeordneten von cdu und csu
sollten bis heute erklären dass sie
nicht an der korona pandemie verdient
haben
die pandemie als marathon wir seien im
letzten besonders anstrengenden drittel
sagt lothar wieler der chef des robert
koch instituts und kein sieht und
trotzdem glücksgefühle die deutschen
handballer spielen unentschieden gegen
vize-weltmeister schweben und träumen
weiter von olympia
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitagabend den sport in der
sendung präsentiert norbert lehmann ein
stück von mir so was gab es noch nie
dass die fraktionsführung der union
ihren abgeordneten ein ultimatum stellt
vor einer stunde lief es ab bis 18 uhr
sollten die parlamentarier schriftlich
erklären dass sie sich nicht an der
korona krise bereichert haben
auslöser waren zwei fälle gegen georg
nüßlein ehemals csu und fraktionsvize
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft wegen
des anfangsverdachts der bestechlichkeit
der frühere cdu abgeordnete nikolas
löbel hat provisionen von rund 250.000
euro eingeräumt über das tauziehen um
das ultimatum christiane hübsche seit
wenigen minuten hat die
unions-bundestagsfraktion gewissheit die
erleichterung ist nicht zu überhören
alle abgeordneten der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion haben bis heute
fristgerecht die ehrenerklärung
abgegeben
das heißt alle abgeordneten der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion haben erklärt keine
finanziellen vorteile im rahmen der
kroner pandemie angenommen zu haben
viele der ehrenerklärungen liegen dem
zdf vor die 243 unionsfraktions
mitglieder sollten versichern dass sie
sich mit der beschaffung von masken und
anderen schutzgüter nicht persönlich
bereichert haben
das war nötig geworden weil gleich drei
abgeordnete fraktion und bundestag diese
woche verlassen mussten wegen
unerlaubter geschäfte mit schutzmasken
beziehungsweise dem vorwurf gegen geld
für aserbaidschan geworden zu haben
scharfe kritik dazu auch vom
bundespräsidenten und das ist schändlich
wer so handelt hat sich im bundestag
nichts verloren
die union die sich jahrelang gegen ein
lobbyregister für den bundestag gewährt
hat legt nun unter schock eine
transparenzoffensive vor
so soll die bezahlte
interessenvertretung für abgeordnete
verboten werden
aktienoptionen müssen offengelegt werden
abgeordneten spenden gibt es nicht mehr
und nebeneinkünfte müssen angezeigt
werden aber erst ab 100.000 euro dem
koalitionspartner spd reicht das nicht
da ist die union bei weitem
zurückgeblieben sie möchte dass erst ab
100.000 euro einzelbetrag eine
unglaubliche summe erst offenlegen und
das ist eindeutig zu wenig wir wollen
uns vom ersten sind es knirscht also an
die gespräche über ein gemeinsames
vorgehen der koalition für neue
transparenz regeln sind auf kommende
woche vertagt
theo koll in berlin wie steht die union
jetzt da ist dass der erhoffte
befreiungsschlag geworden nun im
handbuch politischer krisenbewältigung
wäre es jedenfalls aus dem kapitel
schnelles und hartes durchgreifen
immerhin haben drei abgeordnete der
union binnen weniger tage mandat abgeben
müssen der ansehens schaden aber ist
entstanden und daran ist die fraktion ja
auch nicht unschuldig denn sie hat sich
viel zu lange gegen finanzielle
transparenz und gegen ein lobbyregister
gewährt die heutigen ehrenerklärungen
sind das eine quasi der auftakt wie die
fraktionsvize eben gesagt hat wichtig
werden jetzt aber die politischen lehren
und künftigen regeln und da ist in dem
heute vorgelegten 10 punkte plan sowohl
härte als auch viel spielraum
nebenverdienste ab 100.000 euro genau
anzugeben ist das eine die spd will das
ja schon ab dem ersten cent und daran
sind die gespräche dann heute über
transparenzregeln auch gleich wieder
gescheitert dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus berlin theo koll zu den
korruptionsvorwürfen gegen unions
abgeordnete befragt zdf heute live um 19
uhr 30 den cdu abgeordneten thomas
jarzombek
und die können mitdiskutieren und ihre
fragen stellen auf zdf heute.de in
unserer app auf youtube oder facebook
zur corona pandemie
da gab es heute eine ernüchternde bilanz
von gesundheitsminister und robert koch
institut die lage bleibe angespannt und
die höheren infektionszahlen hätten
nichts mit häufigeren tests zu tun
innerhalb eines tages wurden dem rk ii
12 1834 neuinfektionen gemeldet das sind
2254 mehr als vergangenen freitag
252 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus der bundesweit der inzidenz
wert stieg auf 2 und 4 2 und 70,4 sorgen
bereitet jetzt auch die sogenannte
südafrikanische virus mutation die
breitet sich vor allem im saarland aus
glas bohnsack im grenzgebiet zu
frankreich wie hier in saarlouis laufen
die korona tests auf hochtouren
behörden und politik sind alarmiert denn
im saarland macht die südafrikanische
mutante bereits 15 prozent der korona
infektionen aus aus meiner sicht haben
wir ein gemeinsames interesse daran die
britische ist auf dem weg dominiert zu
werden beziehungsweise uns in vielen
bereichen schon dominanz dass diese
variante nicht auch sich in ganz
deutschland in dieser größenordnung
ausbreitet in deutschland befindet sich
am anfang einer dritten welle besonders
bei kindern und jugendlichen steigen die
infektionszahlen rasant deshalb müssen
trotz des alle regeln weiter strikt
eingehalten werden
die pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei wir
laufen einen marathon
wir befinden uns im letzten drittel und
das ist bekanntermaßen besonders
anstrengend auch weil jetzt noch ein
wettlauf gegen die varianten dazu
gekommen ist und das mächtigste werkzeug
bleiben die impfungen bayern prescht vor
und will dass die hausärzte bereits zum
ersten april mit impfen
auch im rest der republik wäre das
möglich schaffen werden wir das auf
jeden fall also das muss ich dann das
haben wir auch in der influenza zeit
oder in anderen zeiten geschafft dazu
stehen die hausärzte bereit
beziehungsweise lieber gestern als
morgen bislang aber fehlt es an genügend
vakzinen um wirklich breit impfen zu
können
dennoch wollen nächste woche die
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
über eine schnellere einbindung der
hausärzte beraten
für verunsicherung sorgen verschiedene
meldungen zum impfstoff von astrazeneca
wegen möglicher nebenwirkungen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation sieht
derzeit keinen grund den impfstoff nicht
mehr einzusetzen
dänemark aber will prüfen ob es einen
zusammenhang gibt zwischen der spritze
schweren blutgerinnseln und einem
todesfall dänemark island
norwegen und bulgarien haben das impfen
mit astrazeneca vorübergehend ausgesetzt
pablo ziel allagui berichtet ein
impfzentrum in dänemarks hauptstadt
kopenhagen das vakzin des britisch
schwedischen herstellers astrazeneca
wird hier vorerst nicht mehr fern ist
anders in deutschland das für die
zulassung zuständige paul ehrlich
institut hält an dem impfstoff fest und
eilt zur begründung mit bislang gibt es
keine hinweise dass der todesfall in
dänemark mit der kroner impfung mit dem
cupid 19 impfstoff von astrazeneca in
kausale verbindung steht
experten warnen vor panikmache tobias
welte von der medizinischen hochschule
hannover koordinierte bereits zu beginn
der pandemie im auftrag der bhu eine
studie zur möglichen wirkstoffen gegen
korona er sagt im stau vermachen
nebenwirkungen aber sie müssen das
natürlich immer ins verhältnis setzen
zum nutzen wir haben eine sterblichkeit
von 1,5 prozent bei kubi 19 das heißt 15
von 1000 erkrankten menschen sterben
wenn sie das ins verhältnis setzen zu 30
ja nicht tödlichen mit wenigen ausnahmen
nebenwirkungen bei 5 millionen impfungen
dann ist das eben sehr sehr wenig in
großbritannien wurden bereits elf
millionen dosen astrazeneca verimpft
auch hier hält man die nebenwirkungen
für beherrschbar wir sehen derzeit keine
sicherheitsrisiken mit diesem impfstoff
und auch die weltgesundheitsorganisation
betont heute
es gebe keinen grund astrazeneca nicht
einzusetzen
und jetzt in die usa in seiner ersten
großen fernsehansprache macht präsident
biden vorsichtig hoffnungen in der
pandemie bis ende nächster woche sollen
100 millionen impfdosen verabreicht sein
zudem setzt der präsident auf massive
wirtschaftshilfe das gerade
verabschiedete hilfsprogramm umfasst 1,9
billionen dollar millionen amerikaner
bekommen einmal schecks in höhe von 1400
dollar familien mit kindern
steuererleichterungen und arbeitslose
zusätzliche hilfen indes trumps
berichtet nach einem
pandemie erinnert präsident biden an den
schmerz und den verlust den so viele
spürten hoffnung will er aus senden aber
auch warnen appell an alle gemeinsam
gegen das virus zu kämpfen vor allem
sich impfen zu lassen
ich werde nicht nachlassen bis wir
dieses virus geschlagen haben
aber ich brauche euch die amerikaner ich
brauche jeden amerikaner seinen teil
beizutragen
er gibt eine mutige perspektive ab mai
sollen impfstoffe für alle erwachsenen
amerikaner freigegeben werden am
unabhängigkeitstag dem vierten juli
könnten gar feiern möglich sein
wir werden unsere unabhängigkeit als
nation markieren aber auch unsere
freiheit von diesem virus das
impfprogramm und die konjunktur will
biden mit einem hilfspaket ankurbeln
fast zwei billionen dollar dick sein
erstes großes gesetz zustimmung findet
es bei einer mehrheit der amerikaner
auch hier in west virginia
der untergang der kohle trifft viele
hier hat viele haben donald trump
gewählt beides maßnahmen begrüßen sie
ich freue mich darüber wenn man einer
solchen notleidenden gegend helfen und
den leuten 1400 dollar geben kann dann
hilft das hoffentlich miete die
rechnungen zahlen die leute hier sind
damit hinten dran ich bin nicht der
einzige der eine harte zeit hat biden
will die pandemie liebe kämpfen und die
erlahmte wirtschaft aufrichten ist er
erfolgreich könnte er damit gar trump
wähler für sich gewinnen so hoffen
zumindest optimisten unter den
demokraten
es sind verstörende bilder ein sanitäter
schlägt einen gefesselten flüchtling
anwesende polizisten sehen zu der
alkoholisierte syrer hatte zuvor
randaliert und die einsatzkräfte
angegriffen
das ganze ist schon im november passiert
in einer flüchtlingsunterkunft in kassel
jetzt wurde ein video aus einer
überwachungskamera öffentlich und es
stellt sich die frage warum haben die
polizisten überhaupt nicht reagiert und
hat das folgen für sie susanne santino
auf dem video ist zu sehen wie der
sanitäter ein paar schritte zurück läuft
und dann mit
voller wucht den flüchtling der auf
einer trage fixiert ist ins gesicht
schlägt drei polizisten schauen zu und
greifen nicht ein
es gibt eine pressemitteilung der
polizei kassel vom folgetag in der es
heißt dass es sich bei den flüchtlingen
um einen sichtlich alkoholisierten 32
jährigen gehandelt und er randaliert und
erhebliche gegenwehr geleistet habe
nicht erwähnt wird die gewalt des
sanitäters und das nicht eingreifen der
polizei es ist nicht nachzuvollziehen
dass der damalige vorfall überhaupt
nicht erwähnt wurde
das muss jetzt dringend aufgeklärt
werden das zweite ist es ist wieder
einmal in hessen so dass erst dann wenn
etwas öffentlich wird wie heute mit dem
video alle tatsachen auf den tisch
kommen denn das video mit der gewalttat
stammt schon vom november und erst jetzt
äußert sich auch das hessische
innenministerium zeigt sich so wirklich
fassungslos
denn polizisten zeugen einer solchen
straftat werden müssen sie sofort mit
aller entschlossenheit einschreiten
gegen die eingesetzten polizeibeamten
werden disziplinarische konsequenzen
geprüft
der syrische flüchtlinge erlitt damals
einen doppelten jochbeinbruch und gegen
ihn wurden sofort ermittlungen
eingeleitet unter anderem wegen
widerstands gegen polizisten gegen den
gewalttätigen sanitäter wegen
körperverletzung
die staatsanwaltschaft hat uns mit dass
zudem ein ermittlungsverfahren gegen die
am einsatz beteiligten polizisten laufe
es geht bei ihnen um strafvereitelung im
amt
433 millionen euro so viel hat die
bundesregierung im vergangenen jahr für
externe berater ausgegeben das sind
nochmal fast 50 prozent mehr als 2009 10
diese zahlen nannte das
finanzministerium auf eine anfrage der
linken
kritiker sagen der einkauf von
sachverstand seid zu teuer und
angesichts von tausenden mitarbeitern
der ministerien auch nicht zwingend
notwendig zwei bundesländer wählen
übermorgen einen neuen landtag in
rheinland pfalz hat ministerpräsidentin
malu dreyer gute chancen da zeichnet
sich nach dem zdf-politbarometer eine
mehrheit ihrer amtierenden
ampelkoalition ab
in baden württemberg kämen die grünen
mit ministerpräsident kretschmann auf 34
prozent die cdu lege bei 24 die ard 11
spd 10 fdp 11 die linke bei drei prozent
nicht zu vergessen es ist der start ins
bundestagswahljahr und da ist es
natürlich extrem spannend wer mit wem
reagieren kann er mit wem regieren kann
und vor allem will
gerade in baden württemberg könnte
einiges möglich werden von dort
berichtet eva schiller über das ende
eines wahlkampfs auf abstand
er hat seinen wahlkampf auf wenige
virtuelle formate beschränkt weil seine
frau erkrankt ist und der grüne
ministerpräsident in der krise ohnehin
omnipräsent ist seiner beliebtheit tut
das offenbar keinen abbruch und so
stellt kretschmann schon mal bedingungen
für eine koalition
erstens klimaschutz zweitens klimaschutz
tretens klimaschutz oder das ist da sehr
strikt vorangeht dass wir ham pro
aufnehmen müssten
wer das nicht möchte kann mit uns nicht
koalieren so gelassen der
ministerpräsident so angespannt ist
seine cdu kontrahentin erst die
diskussion um schul öffnungen dann die
masken affäre der union im endspurt
versucht susanne eisenmann das
dauer-thema corona loszuwerden
stattdessen über wirtschaft zu streiten
der technologische digitale ökologischen
strukturwandel vor dem die
automobilindustrie steht den muss man
tatsächlich politisch begleiten anreize
förderung aber auch steuerliche
absenkungen die afg will aus dem ärger
mancher bürger über die korona politik
kapital schlagen
corona den crooner frust auch an den den
methoden der regierungen und erschwerend
kommt noch hinzu das ist jetzt auch noch
ein masken skandal der cdu gibt und das
wird man sehen am sonntag wie die bürger
darauf reagieren vom ärger auf die
regierenden will auch die fdp
profitieren und dann endlich nach zehn
jahren opposition wieder mitregieren
ich strebe keine koalition mit rechts
oder links außen an sondern mit politik
fähigen partei und das konzept ihre ich
der cdu den grünen und der spd der
spd-spitzenkandidat hätte nichts gegen
eine ampel
ich kämpfe für eine grün-rote mehrheit
aber wenn die nicht reichen sollte dann
wäre auch eine ampel allemal besser als
ein weiter so mit grün schwarz wer wird
baden-württemberg in zukunft regieren
die chancen stehen hoch dass kretschmann
grüner ministerpräsident bleibt die
frage ist ob er weiter mit der cdu
regiert oder auf ein neues bündnis setzt
der neue hauptstadtflughafen ber will
weiteres geld von den ländern berlin und
brandenburg und vom bund und zwar 1,9
milliarden euro
insgesamt ist der airport mit 4,5
milliarden euro verschuldet wegen
ausbleibender passagiere in der korona
zeit bekommt er bereits für dieses und
letztes jahr staatliche unterstützung
auch mit der neuen hilfe rechnet der br
frühestens 2026 mit schwarzen zahlen
und jetzt handball norbert das deutsche
team spielt in berlin um die
olympia-qualifikation im ersten von drei
spielen ging es heute gegen schweden
deutschlands trainer alfred gislasson
konnte die besten der besten aufbieten
und die erkämpften gegen den
vize-weltmeister immerhin ein
unentschieden in einem packendes spiel
die letzten sekunden laufen das deutsche
team ein tor zurück doch marcel schiller
behält die nerven und trifft 25 25 ein
gefühlter sieg
ein punkt ist besser als gar kein punkt
und deswegen ist natürlich der der
punktgewinn so dermaßen wichtig für das
turnier und deswegen kann man denn sonst
oder können sich schon ein bisschen
freuen drüber
deutschland nach misslungener wm wieder
sicher in der abwehr und mit neuer
lockerheit im angriff die erste halbzeit
gegen gewohnt starke schwedin auf
augenhöhe 14 zu 13 der pausenstand
fehlende entschlossenheit und ein
genialer schwedische torwart führen in
der zweiten hälfte zu vier toren
rückstand erst in der schlussphase fängt
sich das team wohl tor um tor auf und
erkämpfte sich das verdiente
unentschieden
ein guter start in das
qualifikationsturnier platz 24 teams
würde für tokio erreichen zum
wintersport da hat die deutsche
biathletin denise herrmann dem weltcup
in nove mesto im 7,5 kilometer sprint
knapp den sieg verpasst nur sechs
sekunden schneller thierry leck auf aus
norwegen auf platz drei die italienerin
dorothea wierer denise herrmann mit
einer weißen weste am schießstand vier
treffer die basis für ein gutes sprint
ergebnis die 32 jährige als erste
gestartet setzt die bestzeit muss warten
was diese zeit wert ist im fokus steht
die überragende athletin in diesem
winter thierry leck auf aus norwegen
zwar ein fehler stehende aber läuferisch
die stärkste im ziel knapp vor diniz
herrmann
ich habe mich auf jeden fall noch
verlaufen besser gefühlt und das macht
mich sehr optimistisch auch noch für die
nächsten rennen
das gute mannschaftsergebnis
komplettierte franziska preuß am ende
als vierte und beim ski alpin weltcup im
schwedischen are hat lena dürr ihr
bestes weltcup ergebnis in diesem winter
erreicht beim ersten der beiden frauen
slaloms an diesem wochenende wurde sie
als beste deutsche fünfter
es siegte die slowakin peter wohlrath
die sich damit wieder an die spitze des
gesamtklassements setzte
der wintersport morgens zdf ab 11.35 und
jetzt noch kunst einen rekordpreis bei
christie's erzielte dieses werk eine
digitale collage auf den ersten blick
nur kleine punkte doch beim vergrössern
zeigen sich sitzt tausend kleine bilder
zusammengestellt hat sie michael
winkelmann grafikdesigner aus south
carolina
13 jahre lang hat er jeden tag ein
bearbeitetes internet bild hochgeladen
also das auktionsergebnis da haute ist
den 39 jährigen fast vom sofa 69
millionen dollar und das verblüffendste
daran eigentlich könnte dass jeder von
uns zu hause nach warum das
wochenendwetter wird er ganz dich morgen
weiter sturm am sonntag schauer und
gewitter mehr gleich von katharina
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um 10 im
heute journal
hier übernimmt morgen christian sievers
das gesamte heute team danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ein unbeschwertes
wochenende auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
morgen früh kommt das nächste sturmtief
sturmtief lukas macht sich schon hier
über den ärmelkanal bemerkbar
und auch schon im westen deutschlands im
laufe des vormittags sieht der sturm
weiter nach osten dann kann es auch in
norddeutschland durchaus 100 kilometer
pro stunde in böen geben und in den
bergen hier zum beispiel auf der
schwäbischen alb oder im schwarzwald
sind sogar orkanböen möglich
im laufe des nachmittags lässt der sturm
aber mehr und mehr nach und am abend
pfeift es dann eigentlich nur noch an
der nordsee und im schwarzwald
heute nacht ziehen etliche schauer über
uns hinweg und in den bergen ist etwas
schnee dabei es können auch gewitter
unterwegs sei die temperaturen dazu
sinken auf plus 8 bis minus zwei grad
und liegen dann morgen über tag meist
zwischen 6 und 10 grad in süddeutschland
wird es bei 11 bis 14 grad noch etwas
wärmer
für die meisten von uns wird das ein
sehr garstiger samstag mit kräftigen
schauern zum teil mit gewittern in den
bergen schnee dabei dazu der sturm und
nur am alpenrand bleibt es wohl bis zum
abend trocken da scheint die sonne
das ändert sich zum sonntag dann gibt es
nicht auch dort kräftige schauer in den
bergen schnee dabei bei 1 bis 10 grad
schön ab